hi everyone I'm Chloe Cronin a developer
relations engineer here at Google and
I'm going to be doing your post next
recap so we're going to be seeing all
the things that you couldn't experience
online let's go take a look okay I'm
here The Vibes are Immaculate they've
got this very cool art behind me it kind
of looks abstract if you look at it but
it says next when you're in front of it
all right I'm going down the escalator
this is where all the fun begins this is
kind of for the center of all of it
right
[Music]
first stop is going to be to all of our
different sponsor burger and customer
boobs I go to a lot of tech conferences
one of my favorite Parts is meeting all
the people using our Technologies also
they have some pretty cool swag and
there's some really really cool boots
[Music]